The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today, we're going
to have the final presentations
from the student projects.
So they did a lot of hard work.
Some of them are
still working upstairs
and will come down just
in time for presentation.
So just a few slides on format
and how the judging will
happen-- so each team will
have 15 minutes during which
to tell about their
little project
and to give us a little demo.
At least two PlayStation
3s will be set up
by the end of the class.
One will have audio.
The other will have video and at
least two teams will use them.
The others will
SSH in and show you
their programs running
on the PlayStation 3s
that we have upstairs
on the network.
One of the things that they'll
be graded on or scored on
is performance.
Some of the things
we'll do after class
is performance profiling,
to try to understand
how much scalability
you were able to achieve
using parallel processor versus
two versus three, all the way
up to six.
So what we'll do is we'll
set up some time with the TAs
to do the profiling after class.
And you can update your
source code up until 9:00 AM.
So you'll show us how
to do the profiling
and then we can re-run that
at 9:00 AM Saturday morning
and give you updated scores
to change your grades
at the time of grades.
There are six
scoring categories.
Performance-- and this
first Performance category
is essentially what your
performance metric is.
You're going to
define it, hopefully,
and then you'll tell
us how well you did.
Project scope-- this is
essentially a measure,
because each of your different
projects were different.
You picked your own projects.
We'll try to get
an understanding
for how much you tried to
cover and what you actually
did achieve.
So we'll hopefully give
us a good idea of that.
Completeness-- how
robust is your code?
How much you actually
achieve relative
to what you wanted to do?
Are there data races?
Is your code reproducible
with every run?
Presentation and Demo-- so
we've decoupled it here,
just because there are
different ways people will
be doing a demo.
So you can sort of earn points
in different categories.
If you have a really
good presentation
but you might not be flashy,
we'll take that into account.
And then, Performance
Scalability, which we'll
do off and on.
So each one of these categories
score on a 10-point basis
from one to 10, 10
being really good,
and for a total of 60 points.
So for our judging
panel, unfortunately, we
couldn't get virtual Saman
to really work, so Saman
is with us on the phone.
We have Michael Gordon
and Bill [? Theeves, ?]
two graduate students
in Saman's group.
We have myself, Professor
Steve Ward from MIT,
and Professor Weng
Fai Wong, who's
visiting from the National
University of Singapore,
doing a sabbatical year here.
Student presentations
will dynamically
reorder based on who's
available and who's ready to go.
This is a rough ordering
that was picked randomly.
So [? Pumuk is ?] here.
He'll go first.
And then, I see Linear Algebra
Pack so they'll go after that.
The Ray Tracing team is
still in my office working,
so we might have
to bump them down.
Soft Radio Team is here?
Yep.
Speech is here.
Backgammon?
Yeah.
Those guys were ready
having breakfast at 9:00.
The seventh team, Molecular
Dynamic Simulator--
unfortunately, they're not here.
That team is not
physically in Boston,
so they'll present
tomorrow morning
but will not be considered as
competitors in the competition.
There is a countdown clock.
Bill is running his laptop.
You can see it directly
in front of you.
It'll start at 15
minutes and every minute,
it'll tick down, 14, 13,
all the way down to zero.
And you can go into
negative times,
but we'll start
subtracting points.
So the more you run over, the
more points you start losing.
So try to keep under
the time limit.
What about questions?
If there are questions,
we can take those
after the presentation.
If it's a short question--
yeah, let's leave all questions
until after presentation
today, unless there's
something pressing.
I'll try to moderate.
So if we're ready to
start, come up here.